la rupture est quelque chose qui se
constate après une période de je dirais
de de réleion là vous vous suspendez
votre participation à l'intergroupe
qu'est-ce que vous priiez faire de
plus de votre point de vue moi je pense
que c'est de remettre tout à plat et de
dire à un moment donné avec les fill
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à travailler
ensemble là il y a des réunions qui vont
être organisées pour discuter de ça
justement à l'initiative de des
écologistes les écologistes et le PC ont
une position différente de celle qui a
été exprimé on va parler mais juste
comment ça s'est passé ce conseil
nationale pour le coup chez vous il y a
du débat il y a eu il y a eu du débat il
y a eu du débat moi je regrette que la
direction nationale qui a proposé un
texte avec le mot moratoire n'est pas
accepté que un autre texte que nous
avons porté soit soumis aussi au vote
vote qui a eu lieu hier vers 1h du matin
je tiens à le préciser euh donc les nues
ont été courtes euh gagé à 54 % et 54 %
et 46 % donc c'est ça montre que mais
vous l'avez voté ou pas vous le ce
moratoire moi je n'ai pas le droit de
vote mais je n'aurais pas voté mais
votre ligne
je suis membre de droit en tant que
président du groupe mais si j'avais eu
le droit de vote j'aurais voté contre le
texte de la direction nationale parce
que j'estime qu'il ne va pas assez loin
et
qu'il pour moi il ne constitue pas un
acte suffisamment fort pour dire à LFI
ça suffit Monsieur Mélenchon ça suffit
il faut vraiment tout remettre à plat et
reconstruire une autre union je
considère que la nupes qui a été un
accord électoral qui est devenu
progressivement un outil au service de
Monsieur Mélenchon pour ses ambitions
gouvernementales et on sait que ses
ambitions et bien sont quand même
limitées parce qu'il est dans la
protestation et dans la logique du Grand
Soir et bien cette nupess aujourd'hui
pour moi est une impasse politique il
faut recréer une autre
unionors quelle autre union que
aujourd'hui vous pourriez recréer vous
savez moi je suis un enfant la gauche
politiquement l'union de la gauche avec
le PC avec les Radicaux de Gauche a
existé aujourd'hui avec les vers je
pense que LFI tel qu'aujourd'hui piloté
managé par Monsieur Mélenchon ne peut
plus faire partie selon moi de l'union
de la gauche tel que je l'imagine c'est
la
GA
PARFI c'est à LFI d'en décider et pour
être très clair c'est à ceux qui
contestent la ligne politique
idéologique de Monsieur Mélenchon et
bien de prendre leur responsabilité une
union qui pourrait intégrer Bernard cas
par exemple et son mouvement Bernard
casu qui vient de s'exprimer sur une
chaîne concurrente a confirmé qu'il
était
de la gauche mais il considère que LFI
aujourd'hui est un élément qui ne peut
pas moralement être considéré comme un
partenaire naturel de l'union de la
gauche et je crois qu'il a raison au
travers des différents exemples que j'ai
pu vous donner jusqu'à présent donc
elle fille a été créé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et pour les ambitions
personnelles de Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc
je considère que aujourd'hui il s'est
discrédité clairement et pas que depuis
la faire du ramas terroriste il s'est
discrédiqué depuis de nombreux mois voir
même de nombreuses années dans ce pays
le score de 22
% est bien sûr une réalité politique
mais très ponctuelle et on le voit bien
fi est un colosse au pied d'argile qui
n'a pas d'implantation territoriale et
nous nous devons négocier avec ceux avec
qui nous pouvons construire un avenir
pour la GAE la
question